well we're uh getting into election
season now which means that it's time
for two things to make a comeback and
that would be coid and BLM uh and uh
right on Q you know we have this
Resurgence this supposed Resurgence of
coid and the new coid variant they're
talking about masking again and
everything else and also BLM is marching
in the streets again the interesting
thing of course is that BLM uh basically
took a break for the entirety of Biden's
tenure up until right now I guess
because racism had been solved you know
it's an it's a fascinating thing uh
Democrat gets elected and racism is
solved there's no more racism uh until
now racism is back just in time for the
election so here was BLM marching in
Columbus Ohio this weekend let's
[Applause]
[Music]
watch
[Applause]
good so we go black black lives matter
again um black lives matter once again
it's it's good that they're walking in
the streets chanting that because you
know we weren't sure I wasn't sure do
black lives still matter because there
there aren't any there's no you know if
no one is chanting it then how are we
supposed to know and now chanting it
again and we could go oh so black lives
matter well that's good now the
ostensible reason for this demonstration
is the um the police shooting of a woman
named teia young uh in Columbus Ohio and
we're told by the BLM and the media and
you know this is their approved
narrative that teia young was executed
that she was shot dead by racist cops
nearly for trying to shoplift and that's
all so she was shoplifting the way that
they frame it you're you're Imagining
the way what the what they want you to
imagine is that she was shoplifting and
so some cop just walked in and shot her
dead said you're being executed for the
crime of shoplifting and that's all that
happened uh meanwhile tea was six months
pregnant her unborn child was also
killed tragically and the media actually
it's been interesting the media has been
using the phrase unborn child to
describe teia Young's uh child in the
womb so that they have also just now
discovered the human of The Unborn at
least for as long as this story is in
the news so good news for uh all the The
Unborn children of the world right now
that for right now you get to be human
beings for the sake of this tequa young
story and what's out of the news once
it's out of the news then of course
unborn children will go back to being uh
inanimate clumps of worthless matter but
for right now they are unborn babies
somehow
now is it true that tequa young was
killed for shoplifting well no of course
that's not true of course that's
nonsense she was killed um
because what what began what's the
reason why she was having an interaction
with the police in the first place is
because she was allegedly shoplifting so
that's what started this
incident um and and by the way another
point about that that I think is
relevant is that she was allegedly
shoplifting alcohol okay she was six
months pregnant
allegedly shoplifting
alcohol so that's something to keep in
mind really for two reasons because
number one we're told that the reason uh
people go uh and shoplift is because
they're desperate and they're hungry and
and they're starving and they got to
feed their kids um and tequa young is 21
years old had two other kids as well so
this is what we would normally be told
is what she was shoplifting because
she's that well except that she was
shoplifting apparently according to the
reports alcohol she going to feed that
to the kids
well she was going to feed it to her
unborn child apparently if she was
planning on consuming it
herself um so that's something to keep
in mind but
she stole the alcohol allegedly got into
her
car cops tried to stop her from leaving
because she had potentially committed a
crime and that's what comps are there
for if you're committing a crime they're
going to come up and stop you and if you
say I don't want to be stopped I'm just
going to leave they can't just let you
leave because then there's no point in
having law enforcement at all and if
there's no point if there if we don't
have law enforcement there's no point of
having law in the first place and then
we can just have chaos which of course
is what many on the left want but if you
want to live in a in any kind of
civilized functional Society you have
law and law means law enforcement and
enforcing the law means that when the
law enforcement shows up you can't just
decline to be you can't just say well
you know what I I prefer not to be ar
arrested Ed today officer but well if
you don't want to be never mind I okay I
didn't oh you don't want to be arrested
okay well forget it then just go go
ahead go just what did you steal there
oh I got a couple bottles of whiskey
well enjoy go enjoy yourself that's not
how it works so she tried to leave and
uh she was in her car at this point she
refused to get out of the car and
instead she started to drive away and
one of the problems with driving away is
well number one you you're under arrest
because you're trying to steal something
so you can't just leave but number two
there was a cop standing in front of the
car when she started to drive and so she
was driving into a police officer and
that cop then fired a single shot and
teia young was killed that's what
happened Vladimir Putin called the US
Dollar's drop in dominance objective and
irreversible as Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa formerly agreed
to use local currencies in trade instead
of the US dollar as demand for the
dollar weakens the buying power of the
the dollar weakend as well that's why
Birch gold is busier than ever investors
and Savers are looking to harness the
power of physical gold held in a tax
sheltered IRA and you can too you can
protect your IRA and 401K by
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
as the US dollar continues to receive
pressure from foreign countries digital
currency and central banks arm yourself
with information on how to protect your
savings learn if gold is right for you
to text Walsh to 98 9898 and they'll
send you a free info kit on gold with an
A+ rating with a Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers and
countless star reviews I trust Birch
gold to help you diversify into gold if
a central bank digital currency becomes
a reality it'll be nice to have some
gold to depend on again text Walsh to 98
9898 now was the cop in the wrong in
this
shooting well as far as I can tell if he
violated any protocols it was that he
stepped in front of the car of the
suspect now he did he stepped in front
of it before it was moving he didn't
jump in front of a moving vehicle uh she
was parked and there was one cop to the
side trying to get her out of the car
another cop in front of the car and she
was well aware that the cop was there
she chose to drive into him now you know
I'm not an expert in in police
procedures I'm pretty sure it's not
proper procedure for an officer to
physically step in front of the car of a
suspect uh cops aren't supposed to use
their own bodies as barricades as far as
I know so that was dumb on his part no
question about it however the fact that
he's standing there doesn't give the
suspect the right to drive into him
um and once she is driving into him
which she was even if he shouldn't have
been standing there he has every right
to use Force to protect himself because
now this is a Lethal Weapon a car is a
Lethal Weapon being used against him and
he responds with lethal force and was
entirely justified in doing so so teia
young is not a victim here except of her
own poor
choices and and that's the thing that as
always is missing from this
discussion that if black lives matter
and of course they do then the people
who really need to hear that message are
people like teia
young she she did not treat her own life
or her unborn child's life like they had
any value at
all okay so so she's the one who needs
the the news
flash it's the BLM Martyrs themselves
that act like black lives don't matter
they throw their lives away for no
reason uh they do suicidally stupid
things make these these recklessly
self-destructive decisions with no
upside with no possible chance of it
working out in their favor and yet they
do it anyway and they die in the process
like you're shoplifting alcohol to begin
with so you're not starving and
desperate you're stealing booze and
you're pregnant already that's a
decision that has zero chance of making
your life any better at all but then you
get stopped by the cops okay well you're
caught it's done they got you
that's it I they they got you you're
done it's
finished and and here's the thing
they're not even going to put you in
prison nobody goes to prison anymore for
a little thing like stealing you might
get a fine or something maybe you have
to do some community service at most so
it's a relatively minor low stake
situation now I think that shoplifting
should be dealt with much more severely
than it is um I don't think it should be
just a slap on the wrist I think there
should be real prison time but that's
that's not what the situation in our
society today so you can
just take your slap on the wrist and
move on with your life and live to steal
another day or you can try to run away
which in the best case scenario will
mean that when they do catch you you're
going to have additional charges and now
you really will do prison time whereas
before you wouldn't
have um that's the best case the moment
you decide to drive away best case is
that now you're going to spend more time
in in prison than you would have
otherwise worst case scenario is that
you get
shot there is no scenario no scenario
where you drive away and the things and
things work out better for you because
of
it that scenario is not on the menu of
options it doesn't
exist and that's the case for all of the
BLM Martyrs I mean every single
one they they they're in a situation
where the cops they're they're having an
interaction with the police officers
because of the things that they were
doing because of crimes they were Alle
allegedly
committing and rather than just accept
the fact that you're committing a crime
and now the police are here and that's
it they do everything in their power to
make the situation as bad as it can
possibly be for
them and then we're supposed to turn
around and and cry appears like they're
the
victims and no one ever says hey you
know what when when the comps stop you
because you're committing a crime just
don't be suicidally stupid that's
it value your own life enough to to
fight it out in court okay if you really
were being if you really are innocent of
stealing the alcohol then fight it out
in
court you decide to fight it out in the
parking lot and now you're dead and and
you know all of the people who go around
chanting black lives matter none of them
will say
this all of these situations are
extremely
avoidable the reason why I am not
currently dead right now in a parking
lot in Columbus Ohio is because number
one I would not steal alcohol to begin
with I'm just not going to do that and
number two if I if I was suspected of a
crime I would not try to drive
away because I would recognize that that
that is going to make all of my problems
so much
worse so is it because I'm a genius or
I'm some great uh Saint no it's a basic
self-preservation I don't want to make
my problems worse I don't want to make a
situation worse for myself so I'm not
going
to right that's why I'm Not Dead in the
parking lot that's why you're not it's
not because I'm white or you're white
it's got nothing to do with
it people who make suicidally stupid
decisions often times end up dead people
who don't will live longer and that's
it and and that should be the
message just have a little bit of common
sense a little bit of personal
responsibility and and value your own
own
life
um and the problem is in these
communities that this is the thing that
plagues these
communities total lack of Common Sense
total lack of personal responsibility
and a total lack of valuing your own
life and your own
freedom and uh anyone who actually cares
this is what they would be saying if
You' like to see what else I have to say
you can access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there godp speed